notre venus ce soir martin biron qui est
à québec resserre dufour qu'on retrouve
je sais même pas où vous êtes christian
donzé tout bon voila il chassait logique
et à montréal bonsoir à vous trois en
parler parler d'abord de la combine
c'est vraiment le sujet aujourd'hui qui
préoccupe françois legault premier
ministre le milieu de la santé aussi
monsieur dubé si vous avez entendu en
point de presse aujourd'hui vous avez
sûrement remarqué comme moi que quand il
parle de ce sujet là et qu'il parle des
écoles on les sent vraiment inquiet 375
qui ont fermé en trois jours ça commence
à faire beaucoup de classe le
gouvernement le goudron monsieur legault
qui évoque n'était pas pour autant de
l'évoquer parce qu'ils trouvent que
c'est fait ce coupé par un journal mais
quand même il leur renchéri dans cette
direction lanza que oui en effet il
réfléchit à la possibilité de fermer les
écoles pendant un mois pendant le temps
des fêtes est ce que ça veut dire martin
qu'il a perdu le contrôle dans les
écoles il ya deux endroits où il ya des
éclosions dans les milieux de travail et
dans les écoles là où les gens se
promènent finalement alors il la
situation c'est un as à travers le
québec et les écoles
ça devient un enjeu et c'est pas long
alors il doit trouver une solution parce
qu'il ya des difficultés à aérer ces
écoles là il ya de la difficulté
les écoles sont vétustes au québec alors
y est dans une situation il faut qu'il
trouve des scénarios pour que calmer les
éclosions reprendre le dessus fêter noël
et se rendre à la fin de l'année
scolaire alors le scénario qui est sur
la table présentement c'est de fermer un
peu plus tôt en décembre pour reprendre
plus tard en janvier
et aujourd'hui dans le fond il ya mis la
balle ou jeu pour voir un peu comment
les parents comment les professeurs
comment tous les intervenants du milieu
scolaire était pour réagir à cette idée
là mais parlons-en justement christian
des réactions on voit des parents les
paroles sont divisés il y en a qui
disent bon peut-être ceux qui voient pas
comment ils vont se faire remplacer au
travail ce 10 mai un instant puis prévu
les aviser plus vite possible le temps
qu'on s'organise du côté des syndicats
enfin moi ce que j'ai entendu la f1 est
aujourd'hui c'était absolument pas
envisageable de leur côté pour vous en
pensez quoi
moi je pense que tant contre l'épaule
les détails en fait des petits projets
possibles dit claude legault les dalles
c'est normal qu'ils aient des craintes
je suis un peu dérangée par le nom total
des syndicats
je trouve pas ça correct mais c'est vrai
qu'on sent chez chez monsieur françois
legault une préoccupation parce que
depuis longtemps les écoles au fond la
rue verrerie la couverture des écoles
c'était sa priorité c'était sa fierté à
il serait bon ben là il ya un tas de
problèmes mais son aunisiens ça semble
menacer jusqu'à un certain point donc
proposer des solutions alternatives je
trouve que c'est bien
j'espère que tout le monde va collaborer
pour que ça se fasse si ça devient
nécessaire même si c'est évident que
dans un premier temps ça dérange pas
trop de monde mais la réaction du sol
michel c j'aimerais vous entendre aussi
là dessus parce que christian a raison
de dire la priorité monsieur legault
souhaite garder les écoles ouvertes
alors s'il envisage de les maintenir
fermées plus longtemps dans le temps des
fêtes c'est qu'ils jugent nécessairement
quelle situation est sérieuse mais de
notre côté ziv tu as compris rallonger
l'année scolaire la faire déborder en
juin peut-être même jusqu'en juillet
c'est ça qui fait grogner les syndicats
oui en même temps le rouge et tout le
monde le dit on a perdu à ses jours d
comme celle-là au cours de la dernière
année que on peut pas non plus je se
dire ils partiront plus demandeur qui il
rend compte de l'année scolaire habituel
et ce sur tout ce qui m'inquiète le plus
c'est de voir que c'est pas tout le
monde au gouvernement qui chantent la
même chanson
je vais me suis robert jeunesse
l'éducation et comme mon émission ce
midi qui disaient non non il est pas
question de rallonger vacances de noël
on a perdu à sept jours comme ça c'est
tout une heure plus tard j'entends le
premier ministre en point de presse dira
le contraire
ça c'est un peu inquiétant parce que si
une chose qui est un qui est importante
dans une situation de crise n'importe
laquelle pour de crise sanitaire comme
celle ci c'est la cohésion du
gouvernement et non plus en plus
l'impression qu'il ya un seul ministre
d'un gouvernement c'est le premier et on
va falloir qu'on sache où je vous vers
le mas le salon de façon peut-être un
petit peu plus générale sur la gestion
des crédits
oui martin est passé c'est michel raison
un point là tu sais que les décisions se
prennent dans un groupe assez restreint
de ministres dans le club qui est le
premier ministre monsieur dubé et il ya
les ministres économique autour et c'est
vrai que monsieur roberge se fait
souvent prendre dans le détour les
michel parle de la durée mais d'aider
des classes là mais du calendrier
scolaire
mais monsieur robert j'ai aussi fait
prendre avec la question de la
ventilation des écoles quand monsieur
dubé a déclaré
à cogeco au micro de paul arcand qui il
on aurait dû y penser au cours de l'été
à ventiler les classes monsieur roberge
a été prise à partie pendant une bonne
partie de la période de questions
aujourd'hui sur ce point là oui mais
c'est drôle et encore aujourd'hui et
encore aujourd'hui il nos ports un état
des lieux de ceux des écoles où ça va
bien la ventilation des écoles où il ya
un problème nous il faut faire d'autres
rénovations
ils ne le font ils valoir la fin du mois
seulement quand on sait qu'on entend
depuis quand même plusieurs mois de
social après quitte à les examens ce
lundi sur la ventilation
moi je trouve que c'est un dossier je
dis pas que ça aucune importance mais
c'est facile de faire de la démagogie
là dessus françois legault bien fait de
rappeler aujourd'hui que nos praticable
prouvé qu'ils avaient des liens entre
les débits problèmes de ventilation puis
l'école augmentation des cas dans le
domaine de l'éducation
donc si tu me dis j'entends d'un médecin
à une émission de radio qui fait qu'on
peut prouver que les problèmes de
ventilation sa cause est bon et c'est un
dossier que la même gravité soul et que
le retour possible à coimbra liste
cachée cd qui sera une catastrophe non
seulement perdre à un grand prix chose
la ventilation
je dis pas que si rien n'est facile de
faire le show l'opposition fait un peu
de démagogie avec sochaux et mesah
préoccupant même assez monsieur dubé
surtout depuis que le ms a mis l'accent
là dessus en disant faites attention
parce que tout ce qui est en aérosol
quand il fait froid
quand vous êtes dans une classe par
exemple les fenêtres sont fermées
justement parce qu'il fait froid c'est
mal ventilée il ya ce facteur là qu'on
n'avait pas assez pris en compte que
cette contingent par ces gouttelettes
qu'on ne voit pas parce que ces aérosols
c'est tout si cette affaire là c'est ce
qui m'étonne là-dedans martyr je
reviendrai à vous ici c'est la
différence de ton de côté on a un mur
beige qui semble un peu au dessus de ses
affaires de notre côté on à monsieur
dubé qu'elle a profondément inquiet
monsieur monsieur legault qui prêt à
faire des choses monsieur robert j'ai
pas prêt à faire avec la formation des
écoles dans le temps des fêtes
je me demande est ce que ce robert j'y
participe aux discussions quand on parle
des mesures qu'on va appliquer dans le
système d'éducation face à la pandémie
ou est ce qui est complètement passée
induction du nom y est
un décalage entre ce qui se dit ce qui
se passe sur le terrain et ce que dit
aujourd'hui monsieur roberge sur la
question de la ventilation
c'est qu'il a envoyé différents avis aux
directeurs généraux des écoles 3 en fait
le premier en juin un deuxième mode ou
puis un troisième au mois de septembre
où il leur dit ou aux directions d'école
je mets 20 millions sur la table pour
améliorer la ventilation
le problème c'est que les directions
d'école ils sont débordés par la
situation par les changements de gap à
tout vent et si vous trouvez un
entrepreneur c'est ainsi c'est pas
évident il ya une pénurie de matériaux
aussi alors tout seul n'est pas simple
alors à partir du moment où tu envoies
où tu passes une commande du fusil faut
qu'on revoie les ventilations par
exemple date l école ou telle école il
faut que quai des ressources moins
suivie qui va permettre aux écoles de
passer à l'action
et c'est là où on n'a pas de réponse sur
qu'est ce qui a été fait pour comme date
elle comme dans termes de suivi plus
autre que leur appel pas qu'il ouais
mais michel est ce que c'est parce qu'on
appelle un manque de leadership et un
maillot les los ché puis aussi une
nouvelle structure qui est les centres
de service qui qui finalement est répond
pas au mieux
si et peut-être des pires que les
commissions scolaires où au moins il y
avait déjà élu pas pu tabler les centres
de services de toute évidence que ce
soit communication du ministère ils ont
pas l'air d'être pressé et pas autre
chose certaine magie roberge aujourd'hui
au milieu de novembre sais pas si on a
donné suite à ses habits du mois de juin
je me douche puis ce mois de septembre
quelques moments moi je trouve que c'est
moins un problème de leadership qu'un
problème québécois ancien très profond
je trouve qu'on remarque depuis le début
de la crise c'est quand on en fait des
déclarations de bonne foi des
personnages politiques qui sont souvent
sans ces deux ans on va faire ça on va
investir de l'argent et puis la réalité
du support la machine n'est pas capable
de livrer la marchandise
les raisons sont multiples mais reste
que c'est un problème structurel auquel
on est confronté là c'est qu'on réalise
qu'on delà des beaux discours
la machine n'est pas capable de livrer
souvent la marchandise
des sièges c'est le défi de la santé
aussi quand on parle de la machine ça
donnait ça vous met en cause
on va plus long terme le modèle
québécois jusqu'à quel point de le no no
7 son rachat sont très recherchés à quel
point ils sont efficaces moi j'ai des
gros doutes ses revenus non parlant de
mise à jour économique a changé
oui j'ai justement vient de changer la
structure pour faire pour changer les
commissions scolaires pour changer la
machine justement ce qui est évident
c'est que ça a l'air de marcher un peu
moins bon alors c'est tellement de la
fait pour ce thème là allons sur la mise
à jour économique faut quand même en
parler alors c'est un gros déficit 15
milliards il y en aura d'autres dans les
années à venir on peut regarder
peut-être à nouveau le tableau l'un des
projections les enfants de 7.5 pour
l'année suivante
8 je pense pour l'année qui va suivre
alors voyez vous avez les chiffres ici
qui sont déclinées jeudi dans le
désordre mais il reste que le total va
rester le même
martyrs et partis d'opposition qui
disait monsieur gérard bouzid
je viens liste monsieur girard se défend
il reste quand même dans l'entrevue qui
viennent nous accorder on voit que le
willow du contrôle assez resterait il ya
beaucoup de choses qui vont dépendre de
ses négociations avec le fédéral
en fait on n'a pas le portrait global
c'est à dire que c'est encore en
mouvement cette pandémie le alors vous
avez le choix de regarder ça le verre à
moitié vide ou le verre à moitié plein
et clairement le ministre girard décidé
de voir le verre à moitié plein il table
sur un vaccin sur un remède quelque part
en 2021 et il le dit à la fin de son
point de presse en mars qu'on veut voir
vraiment la feuille de route alors et la
situation pourrait empirer on ne sait
pas où on s'en va avec cette pandémie là
il table aussi sur les transferts et la
demande du des provinces elle est très
élevé ce serait étonnant que le
gouvernement fédéral
donne aux provinces tout ce qu'elle
demande parce qu'elle demande énormément
d'argent alors c'est certain qu'il va y
avoir des sacrifices à faire ici au
québec et il y en a un peu parlé il ya
parlé de la croissance économique ça
vous il va falloir produire plus il ya
parlé aussi d'accord deux pas des
compressions défense mais c'est un peu
souffert ce qu on s'envole
il va falloir qu'ils diminuent et c'est
déjà commencé les compressions de
dépenses est ce qu'on demande aux
différents ministères lotis sont moins
sollicités par la pandémie de regarder
un peu deux ans ils auront pas de grosse
augmentation de leurs dépenses lors du
prochain budget de mars
oui mais le premier quand même que sans
eux je ne rajouterai pas offert d'où des
québécois il le répétait encore en
entrevue avez vous l'impression quand
martin vont aussi d'accord si on peut
plus de textes pour plus d'impôts mais
mon service je sais pas mais mais mais
mais moi ce que j'ai retenu c'est la
déclaration de l'ancien ministre des
finances carlos les parents qui est
associé à des coupures que 10 c'est le
temps de dépenser c'est le temps fait
d'investir dans la reconversion de
l'économie dans les industries
numériques et et moi je regarde le
dossier je peux pas te spécialistes mais
dans beaucoup de pays dans le monde on
dit c'est pas le temps d'être dans la
rigueur c'est le temps c'est une crise
historique
c'est le temps de dépenser moi j'ai
rarement de 10 à d'habitude je pratique
toujours les dépenses donc l'opposition
pour chialer mais là c'est clair qu on
n'est pas dans le déficit zéro il ya
l'important c'est est ce que on est
capable de défendre dépensé dans les
bonnes choses de prévoir l'avenir pousse
et en même temps je sais bien que sur le
plan financier
bon je sais pas ce que ça va être dense
moins dans les foyers donc moi qui
dépensent personnellement ça me dérange
pas c'est à moi et michel ce qui est
bête d'avoir fait une mise à jour
aujourd'hui il y en fait nous sommes
quelque part avant les fêtes
mais c'est qu'on est vraiment un
tournant de la maladie de la pandémie
elle-même est ce que ça va empirer
est ce qu'on va voir après tant pire que
celui qu'on a eu une année passée ou si
au contraire on va prendre notre
contrôle personne ne sait on n'a pas de
boule de cristal personnes des finances
non plus au coup de boule de cristal
ce qu'il y a quand même c'est quand même
ironique de voir dans ce
dans cette mise à jour n'a que les
revenus du gouvernement augmente et
robin du gouvernement augmente à cause
des divers programmes des 2des de
soutien financier du gouvernement
fédéral
et souvenez vous de monsieur leubou
critiquer la pcu qui pourrait soit bien
effrayant un certain moment c'est grâce
à ça que soient ses revenus en allemagne
où il faut juste se dire que on est on
est dans cette situation difficile là
pour encore un goût peut-être même un
bon ou alors on à la fameuse le fameux
adage la lumière à la fin du tunnel
bon ben voilà on va cesser là dessus
avec cette interrogation sur tech hier
au bout du tunnel
merci beaucoup pour le panel s'asseoir
on va au bras